we are breaking into programming here on
al-jazeera because in the last few
minutes Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo
Abe a now says he's asked the IOC the
International Olympic Committee for a
one-year postponement of the Tokyo
Olympics and he says that these will now
these summer games will be held by
summer 2021 at the latest he says that
he has been in touch with the IOC with
with the senior management there and has
confirmed with them that the Tokyo
Olympics will not be canceled but will
only be postponed for one year now this
is going to be allegedly a complete
Olympics that includes both the Summer
Games and the Paralympics and our Bay is
is catching this as proof of victory
over coronavirus so essentially when
they are held eventually in 2021 it will
be a celebration of a victory over the
virus as well well you're watching very
very recent pictures that we've just
gotten in of Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a
from Japan speaking about the decision
after a huge amount of international
pressure has been building over the last
weeks and days to eventually postpone
the Tokyo 2020 games they will now at
the very latest be held in summer 2021
well let's now go to our sports
correspondent Lee Wellings who joins us
live he's been covering this from the
beginning well Lee this is clearly no
real surprise given what we've been
seeing over the last 24 hours and this
mounting international pressure but why
this decision specifically now could
they just not hold out any longer this
is of course exactly the news we were
expecting and there is of course no
truth it's just the case of when it was
going to come and now we are there at
the point where this extraordinary
decision has had to be made in these
extraordinary difficult unprecedented
times the only x Olympic Games have not
taken place when scheduled before during
times
and of course at times this coronavirus
crisis has been compared to a war it's
affecting all corners of the globe and
there was mounting pressure of course on
the International Olympic Committee to
let everyone know where they stand now
this is not easy not easy for Japan for
Tokyo which is a lobby everyone at the
IOC because then they had to consider
things like the legal situation they
couldn't just disregard that they had to
think about the logistics of how this
might happen
where they stood but insurance with with
athletes with stakeholders with
broadcasters they can't just make these
decisions and then everyone else
follow-on they need to speak to people
about it but the two key players are the
Tokyo organizers and the IOC and I've
been saying that I knew they were
speaking today that I expected the
decision to come well within the four
week deadline
the IOC gave themselves because this is
the big one all over the world has
stopped there's no sport hardly any at
all being played so let's just get the
news out there and then more detail can
come in due course shortly we sing this
now because of the pressure that we saw
over this last week in Canada and
Australia both saying that they wouldn't
be sending athletes to their to the
games is that what pushed it over the
line when people saw Canada Australia
and Poland journey another same look we
really urge you to call these off that
actually was welcomed by the IOC
actually helps their position legally in
terms of how it's phrased and actually
led them into a position where they knew
that their time was running out to make
this decision that athletes who have
really sort of suffered with this as
everybody had to know where they stand
there they were in a position where in
training it was becoming dangerous so
yeah we were in this position where it
had to be
by the IOC and actually then look a year
ahead and the likelihood dirty olympics
and paralympics
will be together in the summer of 2021
so in the same kind of position that it
was before people will then say what
about the knock-on effect on other
sporting events how does that work
championships in takes place in August
of 2021 well you could also then quickly
say it really doesn't matter does it
people are having to fight coronavirus
everywhere surely a sports event that's
much smaller than the Olympics can be
reached it could even take place in the
run-up to the Olympics they will make it
work and then actually we can start
talking about a celebration as Prime
Minister was pretty hopefully of course
and you'd expect the world to be a far
different place in 2021 that is at the
moment I mean as we are saying that will
be a very different place how is this
all going to play out for athletes
I imagine athletes who've been training
their whole lives for this moment how
will they be taking this news would
there be decisions that are split about
whether or not they want to participate
yeah I don't think you'd be able to find
hardly any athletes that say look we
want this to go ahead in July because it
would be futile there's no way it could
go ahead in July and in fact it's a push
to say that could happen later this year
which was explored and has been looked
at by particularly the Japanese
organizers of this Olympics but actually
athletes it's a job people sometimes
forget that now thinking that job
there's a four year cycle and peaking
and training at the right time it's all
extremely important to them go through
the practice events to my qualifying
events and then you get to the time to
compete now all of this changes and all
of this has to be adapted but again
everything
by the coronavirus crisis because she'd
say okay you have to change you have to
adapt
you have to possibly in some cases
getting funding you have to go through
new qualification procedures all of
these things are relatively small
compared to health and safety and I
think that was one of the growing things
here this Olympics being postponed it's
not just a mere sports matter this is a
mega event that was getting to the point
where people were getting very anxious
about their health and safety so the
absolute first thing to do is say it's
off postponed and then people can start
putting them very very complicated
procedures in place for next year of
course we'll know far more about where
we stand with each passing day let alone
in two or three months or when the
Olympics was due to take place this year
by then all know far better how we stand
the next year